are you guys Lady Gaga is shouting love
from the rooftops as the one does for
you Gaga Michelle Turner et's Michelle
Turner interviewing Lady Gaga last night
at the SAG after Foundation's third
annual patron of the artists awards and
of course the show how to ask her about
that engagement to Christian Kirino why
did you you want to keep it so private
or so longer why now is it great to just
shout that love from the world uh you
know I think it's always wonderful to
shout love from the rooftops
isn't it lovely to just shout love from
the rooftops you're not but we got to
talk about Gaga who actually hit the red
carpet at the SAG after foundations
event showing off the big engagement
rings then proudly probably I mean she
was posing with she knew her angles you
know what I mean like you got again you
got a shout love from the rooftop and
show where you got it you know but it's
kind of amazing because you know the
engagement was really low-key right
really look he wasn't until she
announced it just last month during a
speech and finally you know referring to
Christian as her fiance which finally
confirmed what we all already assumed
anyway well and a source told us that
Gaga has been keeping this relationship
a lot more private than she did with
Taylor Kinney you know she's but trying
to keep it to themselves but last night
that rock and and a glowing Gaga who was
on full form you mentioned the glow I
have to say really quick I am digging
this look that she's been doing on a lot
of red carpets lately where it's like
it's the no makeup but yes but heavy
makeup look and just that glow girl is
glowing inside and out cuz she is happy
in love and she has been ever since
February 2017 when et confirmed the
relationship that the pair actually had
shared some adorable PDA moments just
ahead of her big Super Bowl halftime
show and then shortly after the
engagement another source told et that
she is in fact on top of the world and
that Christian is part of that they kept
their engagement private so it wasn't
such a media storm hashtag goals
[Music]